et si tu devais donner une définition de
toi-même que dirais-tu
ing bonsoir tu es connu comme le
Michelangelo du métro de New York pourtant
tu ne veux pas qu'on t'appelle le gratitis
pourquoi
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je veux dire  J'ai dessiné dans le métro à New
York pendant cinq ans, c'est comme ça que j'ai
gagné le nom de graffeur mais
euh le problème est que les gens ont tendance
à ne penser qu'à une seule chose quand
ils pensent au graffiti et en réalité
je l'ai fait  beaucoup de choses différentes quelle était l'
importance d'elitchinsky et de William
Burruss dans votre décision de peindre
euh bien c'était deux des premières
influences je suppose et dans Burrows
à cause de l'idée conceptuelle de ce qu'il
faisait avec la littérature et
avec le psychédélique vous savez  expérience
et avec euh avec la façon dont il prenait
les choses et les découpait et
les changeait et trouvait
une sorte de sens spirituel ou
psychédélique à l'intérieur des
choses normales que vous connaissez et pour alishinsky c'était
plus juste formellement
euh ses choses étaient quelque peu similaires
à  ce que je faisais à ce moment-là et
j'explorais aussi des choses en faisant des
choses abstraites qui évoquaient des images et d'autres
sentiments et choses
quand as-tu peint pour la première fois
dans un métro dans un appartement ou dans une
boîte de nuit quand était-ce dans le métro  à
New York en 1980 c'était le début et
qu'as-tu peint
quand dans le métro j'ai commencé à dessiner
euh à la craie parce que dans le métro je
ne dessinais pas sur les murs je
dessinais sur un panneau publicitaire vide
et ils n'en ont pas assez  publicités ils avaient
un truc vierge alors j'ai commencé à acheter de la craie
et à dessiner sur ces choses avez-vous
commencé à peindre dans le métro parce que vous
n'étiez pas en mesure d'entrer dans un vrai musée à
cette époque c'était une sorte de musée pour
vous c'était  l'endroit idéal pour que les gens
voient le travail mais aussi à l'époque je
ne vendais pas de travail ou n'exposais pas dans
des endroits sauf dans des boîtes de nuit et vous
savez des petits endroits comme ça mais
vraiment parce que le métro avait à New
York je veux dire il y en a des centaines de
milliers  de gens tous les jours qui passent
devant le drone donc vous ne pouvez même pas dans un
musée, vous ne pouvez pas demander cela et quand a
fait l'un de vos tableaux, je suis sûr que le
vrai musée pour la première fois
euh combien d'années plus tard donc par  19 1981 ou
82 a été ma première grande exposition à la Galerie,
puis en 83 ou 84 dans les musées oh et
quand avez-vous rencontré Andy Wells,
euh, la
première fois que je l'ai vraiment rencontré, c'est quand
il est venu à ma première grande exposition à New
York avant  que je l'avais rencontré quelques
fois mais juste en tant que fan vous savez demander
un autographe et complètement nerveux
et ne savait pas quoi dire mais ensuite
par l'intermédiaire d'un ami commun il est venu à mon
exposition et après la première
exposition nous avons commencé à échanger  travailler et
devenir de mieux en mieux amis,
puis je suis venu à chaque exposition et nous sommes
devenus au cours des trois ou quatre dernières années,
vous savez, des amis pour bavarder au
téléphone et sortir pour manger et des choses
comme ça et vous avez rencontré Basquez ou tout
seul  non non je connaissais Jean-Michel quand je suis
arrivé à New York pour la première fois parce qu'il a
grandi à New York mais à Brooklyn mais
il a commencé à traîner sur la scène à
New York à peu près au même moment que moi
donc je l'ai rencontré en 1981  panier
peint avec la guerre mais tu ne l'as jamais fait pourquoi euh en
partie parce que Jean-Michel est-ce que je veux
dire j'ai fait comme deux ou trois petits
tableaux avec Andy que nous avons donné à
Madonna pour euh son cadeau de mariage quand
elle a épousé Lauren est-ce que tu te sens comme ton
les cheveux d'Andy bien d'une certaine manière et
c'est presque trop à
prendre tu sais c'est comme ça je veux dire c'est
trop lourd à porter
ouais en quelque sorte sur tes épaules pour dire je veux
dire je comprends pourquoi certaines personnes établissent des
liens et nous  avait des choses
en commun sur la façon dont nous, euh, tu
sais, traitait l'art et la vie et rendait les
choses plus courantes et plus faciles pour les gens, mais il y a
aussi beaucoup de différences, je veux dire, nous sommes vraiment je veux
dire, je ne pouvais pas  j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait
sans Andy faire ce qu'il a fait en premier qu'est-ce qu'ils
vendent dans votre magasin à New
York appelé Pop Shop
euh surtout tous les imprimés vous savez
des choses imprimées comme des t-shirts et des affiches et
des jouets des choses comme ça surtout des t-shirts bien que
vous  ne pensez pas que c'est une sorte de
marchandisage qui peut être mauvais pour votre
cœur, vous savez que cela peut le minimiser non, je veux dire
au début, il y avait
des critiques du monde de l'art et cela
a probablement eu un effet sur les prix
du marché de l'art et  la même chose pour
Andy quand Andy a fait des films et a
interviewé des magazines aussi ouais ouais c'était
je veux dire les prix des choses d'Andy quand
il était vivant étaient comparés à ceux de Jasper
John ou du Liechtenstein était très très
bas ouais mais qui s'en soucie vraiment je veux dire je
pense que le  la valeur réelle d'Andy est beaucoup
plus importante que LinkedIn Center
Jasper John donc je veux dire que je ne le fais pas seulement
pour l'argent donc je pense que tu ne
sais pas ouais et de toute façon pour moi la boutique est
euh
correspond exactement à ce que je  fait dans
le métro tu sais je veux dire si je n'aurais pas
fait la boutique et été élitiste et
juste euh un peintre cher alors je
pense que ça aurait été plus mal de
rendre les choses disponibles que
penses-tu de la figuration française Balance
people  comme les combas De Rosa eh bien ouais eh
bien je suis ami avec la plupart d'entre eux je
veux dire que je les ai rencontrés pour la première fois je pense à
DeRozan combust et Baron et grand-mère
Blanchard et Louis bras
très tôt comme 1982 ou 1983. ouais vous
aimez ce qu'ils sont  peindre ouais eh bien je
pense que je pense qu'il y a maintenant il y a
une sorte de culture internationale
je veux dire je pense qu'ils ont grandi sur beaucoup
des mêmes choses que j'ai grandi sur
si c'était vous n'avez jamais dessiné avant
votre
univers Banks ouais vous peignez directement  oh ouais
le dessin avec de la peinture ouais parce que c'est
un direct et qui fait partie de la raison pour laquelle
je suppose que le nom de
graffeur est resté parce que même la façon dont je
fais des peintures est d'une certaine manière comme si
quelqu'un faisait des graffitis parce qu'il
n'y a pas de croquis  ou un plan c'est juste
directement de ta tête sur eux tu
aimes quand tu peins des
gens qui te regardent c'est une sorte d'
événement tu aimes beaucoup c'est
comme quand tu peignais dans le
métro maintenant ouais on y était habitué tu sais
parce qu'après être allé dans le métro
aussi longtemps, je suis devenu beaucoup plus à l'aise
avec ça et maintenant je fais beaucoup de fois
des peintures murales à l'extérieur ou dans des écoles ou
des hôpitaux des choses comme ça et euh et il
y a généralement des gens qui regardent mais ce
n'est pas un problème parce que vous êtes  non tu ne
regardes pas les gens tu regardes
ce que tu fais donc et
j'ai toujours de la musique forte et donc je
sais juste ce que tu écoutes quand tu
travailles euh
surtout de la musique de danse comme la musique qui
tu danserais et j'ai
beaucoup d'amis qui sont DJ à New York
donc les gens font toujours des cassettes pour eux combien
coûte une peinture de toi maintenant
euh je ne sais pas maintenant c'est ridicule
en fait ouais je veux dire j'y suis allé  pour voir le
défilé il y a un défilé à Paris en ce moment
euh de dessins que je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
mis la chemise c'est des dessins que ce
marchand a acheté à différents endroits
et c'est incroyable pour moi le prix auquel
il vend et je peux  Je ne
crois même pas à quel point je veux dire beaucoup, je suis
des centaines de milliers de dollars, je veux dire
pour de petits dessins qui étaient des autographes que
j'ai faits pour des gens comme vingt-cinq
mille dollars, je veux dire, c'est complètement
fou, je pense que le marché de la cour est
complètement fou en ce moment  Je veux dire qu'il n'y a
pas d'équilibre, vous savez, par rapport à la
valeur réelle de quelque chose, vous savez et
pour moi, c'est effrayant parce que
j'avais toujours l'habitude d'aller aux vernissages et je
faisais des dessins pour des centaines de
personnes et maintenant ça me fait réfléchir à deux fois
parce que les gens prennent le dessin et
qu'ils le vendent pour autant d'argent
maintenant c'est fou donc vous ne savez pas si
quand vous signez quelque chose ils le veulent
parce qu'ils le veulent vraiment ou
s'ils pensent juste à l'argent parce que tout
le monde vient  pense à l'argent maintenant c'est
comme dessiner des billets de banque tu veux dire ouais
ouais et beaucoup de gens qui
collectionnent l'art en ce moment
ne se soucient même pas de ce que c'est, ils ne
regardent même pas la chose qu'ils sont seulement c'est
comme un investissement c'est comme  l'
immobilier ou jouer à la bourse c'est ça
où on peut voir tes tableaux à Paris
en ce moment
euh ben il y a une exposition de ces petits
tirages de dessins que j'ai fait en 1983 qui
sont à cette Galerie qui s'appelle 1900 2000
rue Bonaparte une petite galerie
si  vous n'étiez pas en train de préparer quel peintre
voudriez-
vous être disons
euh
[Musique]
Je veux dire que la réponse évidente est Picasso,
je veux dire que chaque peintre veut
être pour le costume mais si ce n'était pas ça
alors euh
et puis je  Je suppose qu'Andy sera le prochain
choix
et si vous deviez donner une définition de
vous-même, que diriez-vous que vous connaissez
des artistes dans le vrai sens du monde, ce qui
signifie que vous pouvez faire tout ce que vous
savez, je veux dire que je peux
construire des choses et faire dessiner, vous savez  des
livres pour enfants et des meubles design
et construisez des bâtiments ou savez-vous que c'est
vraiment une vraie vie